dans ce centre de tri de granby jour
après jour depuis des semaines les
matières recyclables s'accumulent faute
de pouvoir les exporter en chine
c'était de malo qui était destiné pour
la chine mais présentement je sais que
c'est ballot je ne peux pas à les
envoyer parce qu'il ya un taux de
contamination trop élevé c'est tout des
ballots que je vais avoir procès c'est
qu'on va rouvrir on va commencer le
travail
c'est que la chine qui était jusqu'à
tout récemment le principal acheteur
mondial a décidé d'imposer des critères
de pureté beaucoup plus sévères pour les
matières récupérées qu'elle importe et
même de bannir plusieurs types de
plastique ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui les
ballots de papier qu'on exporte doivent
convenir tout au plus un demi pour cent
de matières et des érables
c'est comme si la chine avait fermé ses
frontières mon papier journal ce sens
pour 500 à l'heure h en chine
pour julie gagné ça a été un choc on
prend une grande respiration offert pas
en arrière il faudrait faut trouver une
solution
moi je baisse ma cadence de production
est gérée engager du personnel pour
remettre sur la ligne de cris pour
essayer d'arriver le plus possible aux
qualités que la chine nous demande pour
l'industrie québécoise du recyclage ces
nouvelles conditions un impact majeur
si que les 27 centres de tri qu'on
retrouve au québec exporté jusqu'à tout
récemment 60% des matières récupérées
principalement vers l'asie notamment en
chine au québec actuellement on y danse
comme que dans une crise localement au
québec on a très peu de marché pour
écouler les matières qu'on récupère
l'exportation qu'on a vécu des masses et
ridules qu'on a vécu au cours des dix
vingt dernières années à françois qui
des entreprises de recyclage au québec
ont dû fermer leurs portes
ce qui est très malheureux donc on ait
pris si on veut que une matière qui
s'accumulent dans les 102 selon la
ministre québécoise de l'environnement
certains de ces centres de tri sont
aujourd'hui à risque en raison de leur
vétusté qu'on dit c'est qu'il y en a
trois qui sont dans une situation à
risque élevé c'est asus c'est à dire
avec la fermeture donc du marché de la
chine où l'entreprise est en grand
danger ou le matériel qu'ils vont
travailler dans le fond sortira pas avec
une qualité qu'on va trouver preneur
selon nos informations ce sont les
centres de tri de koans ville de
granby de montréal qui pose problème et
qu'ils ont besoin d'investissements
majeurs
ici au centre de récupération de
montréal le plus important au québec les
stocks s'accumulent depuis des semaines
cette photo satellite de septembre
dernier nous montre que le terrain était
vide alors que maintenant
la cour est pleine les matières
recyclables s'accumulent partout autour
du bâtiment
une situation qui n'inquiète pas le
responsable de l'environnement à
montréal et ont assuré qu'ils seront
disposés dans un avenir assez court pour
au niveau des compagnies qui vont
racheter pour faire la pâte à papier
puisque dans l'axé ça s'accumule ça
s'accumule effectivement mais c'est pas
il y en a beaucoup mais il voit une
supposée soyez pas de problème le groupe
tiru qui est le gestionnaire du centre
de tri n'a pas souhaité répondre à nos
questions alors qu'à montréal le site
déborde à green bay malgré les
difficultés on accepte les surplus qui
viennent des autres centres de tri
la récupération et en provenance de
l'île de man vient dans certains centres
de tri les choses vont beaucoup mieux
comme ici dans celui de lévis près de
québec où des millions de dollars ont
été investis pour acquérir des
technologiques points comme ce lecteur
optique qui permet d'améliorer la
qualité du tri qu ici on a développé de
nouveaux marchés on va exporter en corée
le sedan l'indonésie via des courtiers
et vers d'autres pays d'asie
malgré tout il n'entend pas pour autant
laissé tomber le marché chinois
il ya d'ailleurs des représentants de
papetières chinoise qui doit venir
prochainement dans son usine on venir
faire des contrôles qualité directement
au centre de tri avant même qu'elle ait
les contenants repartent pour pour
l'asie dans cette crise une opportunité
de développer une véritable économie du
recyclage au québec le gouvernement
couillard va d'ailleurs annoncer
prochainement qu'il injecte quelques
millions $ pour soutenir les centres de
tri pour les aider à se moderniser
j'ai pas envie que les québécois et les
québécoises qui ont posé les gestes
qu'ils payent pour le recyclage
rappelons-le est et puis que cette
matière là parce qu'elle est pas bien
trier sans mal au final
dans des dépotoirs à l'union des
municipalités du québec ou si on
surveille de près la situation
ce qui est important pour nous c'est
qu'on enfouit rapaces et matière là on
va trouver des solutions il faut trouver
des solutions
je pense que dans les conseils
municipaux au cours des prochaines
semaines des prochains mois les gens
vont aller pour l'éducation de savoir
comment les élus s'assure que cette
question là est prise en considération
et qu'on évite d'aller vers
l'enfouissement un site d'enfouissement
ou d'incinération c'est la dernière
chose qu'on qu'on souhaiterait voir
autant les centres de tri ligne
politique le gouvernement parce qu'il y
aurait une crise de confiance à ce
niveau là au niveau des yeux des
consommateurs
quant à julie gagné elle souhaite
maintenant moderniser ses installations
pour assurer la survie de son centre de
tri